like the patriarchy disguising itself is
feminism like if you're using feminist
terms because it's like you know if
there's men out there that like want to
have sex with girls like what best way
to like get them to have sex with them
then tell them like it's cool like you
know what I mean like it's feminist to
like be sleeping around with people you
know what I mean I feel like reverse
psychology yeah it's like more in favor
of men than it is on women because then
it also weakens you as a woman you know
as I said as we said before like it can
um it can damage you it can uh affect
your self-worth whether you want to
accept it or not and then you're going
to also like lower your standards you
know and just and go for anything and